you guys are missing a Backstreet Boy
today we're yeah you're missing somebody
well no I mean you're missing somebody
else how is it having somebody that
versatile and somebody like chance in
the band now first of all it helps the
band tremendously when you have a genius
in van no no I changed my mind chance no
we are huge fans of his we love his work
and you know we actually didn't realize
he was a fan of ours until when we got
on set we were filming with him he's
like listen I just wanna let you know
guys office huge fan but I collected
your action figures when we did a thing
for a Burger King like long time ago he
was like 10 years old but chance has
your action figures he said that he
drove around to a bunch of drive
throughs try to collect those Burger
King action figures that we did with
Stanley because we were too cool we
didn't want to be dolls right so we're
like we'll be action figures
[Music]
what does it mean having a Super Bowl
commercial I mean it's as big as getting
to the game I mean it's such an honor to
be asked by Doritos to even do something
like this and then to be involved with
chance the rapper it's a dream come true
you know and we have so much fun on set
we cannot wait for the world to see it
you know I mean it's gonna be hopefully
one of the best Superbowl commercials
association with Superbowl we did what
was in 2001 we had the honor of singing
the national anthem actually be back now
to the commercial wait a minute when you
say who knows what'll come next year it
sounds like that sounds like a halftime
vid that you're putting in your [ __ ]
right now we're focused on the thing
we're focused on all the things that are
ahead of us right now we still have a
biggest residency we have a February in
April which is our last run
then we're gearing up for a tour we're
gonna go on DNA world tour let me just
got now I would just drop by the way got
yes I also got nominee for a Grammy so
we got to go to the Grammy Awards and so
we got a big year ahead of busy I hear
you and that was the perfect answer I
mean that your PR people are happy but
one day one day I feel like you would be
great on that stage at that halftime
show would be
can we talk about Vegas and you know
everybody if everybody is jumping in the
Hat now they're trying to get into that
Vegas residency you guys have been there
how is it bid and what does it mean to
be in Vegas you know Vegas has allowed
us to be the best action boys that we
possibly could be you got Carter because
I mean we a lot of people don't know we
signed up to just do nine shows there
and two years later we'll be baby shows
in so it's you know it's it's been a
good it's been a great run the community
is welcome too soon you know they've
allowed us to put on the best show
possible you know we we want all these
possible words for having the best show
and and we're just we're grateful you
know it's come back around people are
buying back into the back ship boys and
you know we just love you what we're
doing trying to be good at what we do
and here we are